we went to a breastfeeding class last
night sweet for you yeah yeah just you
and
Sam it's funny like even in your 30s
like all like if you sit down in a
classroom environment like all the
archetypes of students still exist oh
yeah you know yeah like was a lady like
came in like sat like front row and then
asked like way too many questions at the
end which like I shouldn't judge because
she's a pregnant woman and she's
probably pretty scared for labor yeah
you know I could tell even everyone else
in the class including all the other
pregnant ladies were like all right
[__] we're trying to go home wrap it
up yeah you know actually one more sorry
guys I have another
question teacher's pet all these
pregnant women got their one tit out
they're like can you shut the [__] up
man yeah I'm can we get going it's cold
in here I'm trying to put my tit back in
my shirt was it a hot teacher
what hold on hear me out hear me out
hear me out what hear me out I'm just
saying and a bunch of husbands in there
just uncomfortable yeah and you're all
looking at each other you just how you
doing yeah how you doing how many weeks
how you how many weeks yeah yeah
exactly yeah you know just uh had my
last land party so you
know yep life's
over no just it's like what do you say
boy what is it a girl it's
like we got uh
quintuplets so we got to move to
Missouri the last Land part is
goodp to ever doing that again I guess
you had our last Mario Party session yep
you game at all
yeah I used to not anymore as as of
exactly yesterday at 6 o' that was my
last time gaming for a
while man they really bullied Drake on
that ad lib so funny they you saw the
two mixes wait what which one what are
you talking about uh Benny X tweeted the
other day he's like it the mix is fixed
so download the new one but they they
distributed a new mix where they took
out a bunch of effects and then they
they turned down Drake money for fun
they turned it way down yeah no way yeah
it was just like in the background
that's the new one on Spotify it was and
then people it's so funny people
complained yeah obviously they said bro
it's not that like it's just a meme it's
fine yeah and that that like helps the
song yeah they always do that [__] to
Drake yeah I think it's funny I mean
those little animations where it's like
money for fun and it goes back yeah so
funny I know Drake was looking at them
shits like just angry as [__] it's I
didn't say it like that it wasn't like
that you just got that grin when you're
getting torched yeah by the group and
there's nothing you can say just like
all right all right all right yeah no
cool yeah cool no no fair play fair play
nice [__] stop [__] back off
he's T and Benny X yo you better get a
new [__] mix in my inbox in the next
hour
bro are he's doing a koi yo bro I think
we should do a different mix what if we
turn it down yeah this shit's really
funny but like let's turn it down a
little bit turn it down a little bit
Yeah Yeah it maybe it's a little
overpowering we don't have to but like
we should maybe the humor is taken away
from like the point of the song you know
I'm not trying your production I want
that to shine you know like I don't like
I feel like your beat is getting lost in
the noise of this so like okay like it's
cool but we just you know we want people
the vibe okay we're turning it up all
right yeah no that's cool yeah you're
turning it
up no the label actually wants us to
turn that [__] way up yeah they love the
sketch I can see it dude Drake oh my God
the Yeet song is going absolutely
Bonkers man Tik Tok congratulations team
has given us some crazy numbers on this
listen so we've already reached out to
Mike Dean and uh we're going to go ahead
and turn that ad lib up more we think
it's just you know super smart to double
hello Drake it's going to be actually
the we're going to he must be in the
Bahamas yeah yeah lost reception we're
going to release a sped up version
that's just that ad lib is that okay
just money for fun money for fun money
for fun we're going to release a Tik Tok
version where your verse actually never
comes on and it's just Yeet setting up
for money for
fun how's that sound to
you great yeah
great yeah hi yeah we're going to go
ahead and do a Tik Tock version
um yeah we're going to need you to come
in the studio and save money for fun
about 30
times yeah we think it's just good to
get some variation in the track
so yeah that'd be great wait did I show
you that that Tik Tok of that dude
farting on the
dog happy she to the
Parky sometimes they like that little
bit of like to hey
[Music]
byebye I think the best part about that
is him like plying it off sometimes they
like that like the little the little
toot for all the comments are so funny
they're like dude if someone farted on
my dog I would throw
hands I don't think so man
if oh man I'm throwing ants oh man
scroll up dude don't found it
like keep keep playing it I got to see
that again that was so good like
that dog like moves away too
byebye the next one is really
good if you're listening on audio what's
happening right now is like a guy in a
bulldozer is running over a dog
oh Jesus
Christ just the music
yeah we're just like huh it's a dog
fight oh oh yeah yeah what that's a pit
bull attacking a
child a dragged at about 10t this is
hilarious man wo hi doggy hi doggy a big
boy
boy no wait there's one where he throws
it at he farts in his hand throws it at
the
dog hi doggy he's a bigy he's a big
boy damn he's just a SK sometimes they
like you little
like yeah have a good day gra
day go to this part sometimes they like
yeah that that sentence is so funny
sometimes they like that sometimes they
like it sometimes they like a little
sometimes they like a
little do you ever microwave your [__]
and feed it to them sometimes they like
that oh I have a little diarrhea in a
tubberware here glass Tupperware so I
can carry with me all day yeah do you
ever take one of their turds on
microwave in and eat it and suck the
juice out sometimes sometimes sometimes
I like that sometimes I like that a
lot